we are still seeing the Ripple effects
of the winter storms over the holidays
not just with travel but in other ways
as well indeed now the impact is hitting
the American Red Cross after it had to
cancel hundreds of blood drives in a
time when blood was already in short
supply Ken's Charles joining us live
this morning with their pleas for help
Candace good morning
good morning to you good morning folks a
simple act of kindness can go so far but
it also can save a life and you can save
a local life like Clark Dumont who's not
only been a blood transfusion recipient
but he's also donated for a number of
years as well tell us a little bit about
that transformation that change going
from donating blood to 212 kneading
blood well it's one of those things that
you never wake up that day and think
that I'm going to need blood I'm a very
healthy person otherwise and all of a
sudden one day I came down with
Guillain-Barre syndrome and I needed to
be hospitalized for a week and thank
goodness that donors to the Red Cross
were there for me in a time of need and
I've received this life-saving potion
for a week and I'm fine a life-saving
gift right and we're so happy that
you're fine but do want to go back as
well to all the work that you've been
doing 75 units right that you donated so
far tell us about what it means to be a
Blood Donor well first of all you want
to talk about a good feeling it's all
about the good feeling and knowing that
you're helping giving the gift of life
and uh you know the the Red Cross makes
it really easy too uh it's like here's
this app that I can go on and very
simple and I just sign in and and
they'll remind me when it's time to give
and I'll sign up and I'll do my EZ Pass
I call it Easy Pass fast pass and and
then when I get here that day I just go
in the chair and I give and it's my time
you know when I do that it's my time I
love it thank you so much Clark for what
you're doing in the community and for
being here with us today we're so happy
you're here with us and you guys again
it's a quick process could take about an
hour from coming down here and signing
up and all that good stuff we recommend
of course drinking water being very
energized as well as you know eating as
much as you need to uh it's again very
quick process and if you do this now you
have a chance to enter a raffle to win
Super Bowl tickets pretty cool right we
haven't covered with all the details on
our website eightnewsnow.com guys wow
that is incredible and uh thanks to
Clark as well